now by the way just to remember there's
the derivative there's a primitive we're
starting from the middle okay we're
gonna start with the middle go outside
so let's start with our typical one side
okay so now we know how to differentiate
is okay now let's just keep that there
for a second what about the derivative
all was good okay no that's enough for
me to now start thinking about okay what
were the primitive members your side
beat right because I'm going from a
function to its limit 'iv right is the
same as going from a derivative back to
its original function that's pretty neat
okay so if i've got this relationship
here right which ought to be the same as
the relationship here what would I
expect to have come from if I end up
that side the answer is okay so it's
good it's got to be something to do with
pause right but it's not just regular
clothes because if I differentiate that
test it out right I won't may have
downside I'll land on negative so that's
why you have to put a minus there and
you'll get a double negative and will
cancel out and that's why you end up
with oh okay well of course you got the
constant fly over this time okay all
right now the same point that I can make
from here to here right that
relationship ought to be the same as
this relationship yeah
so if I differentiate and I ended up
with cause I must have started for all
okay now the next W you know your estate
for your next function would be okay
let's think about this for a second
we'll come back to him in a minute
but what will the derivative of candy
so so let's just note that okay before I
do I have to think about this guy okay
that means that if I get sick square
okay and I asked you where did this come
from
if this is a function what was its
primitive where you can see it's going
to be the same relationship here right
so good up one level it's going to be 10
X plus C the dubious x squared isn't all
that interesting because we don't really
deal with it wasn't much but from memory
anyway now I want to come back to attend
right now it's interesting right because
we don't have something which ends up
your differentiator and you know Ted
just calm down okay at least out of this
set right so hmm we work out what would
it some primitive be that it's on 10 is
really destroy him for so long cause
okay all right so just think about that
for a second I'm going to leave that
there let it simmer and I wonder if for
you okay well it is a question but it's
not question rule will you remember I'm
ending up at this I differentiate and
this is what I get
not this is a lot of different think
about it now I want to try and get you
there let's have a think about not just
trigonometric functions you're gonna
wonder why I put this here but what
about log functions log X what's the
what's the derivative of a log function
just one over okay
now that tells you that if you get 1
over X right I already know how to
differentiate this this is going to be
what that that's X to the minus 1 so
therefore it's derivative or to be minus
1 upon x squared and in the same way as
it were from here to here right this is
going to be this is where I came from
this is log
see all right now log functions on there
are they're pretty boring right we're
used to stuff like this logo say oh I
don't know maybe say x1 okay by the way
I'm deliberately through it is up I will
I will come back to this one we'll come
back to you okay
a previous of malfunctions you've really
don't need to worry about what's the
derivative of this what we're all not
using I'm using chain rule right because
I've got a a function of a function
right so how does chain or work
specifically for logs now this is this
is generally speaking right this is -
when I call back there that's a bit nice
because I'm maybe I should call
something else which might follow
G okay now I wonder I wonder for how
many of you the clogs are turning if
what I can say look if I differentiate
this I'm gonna end here right therefore
don't be that guy in the movie theater
who's like it's the bad guy there was
like can you see how I've been going
down this some down this table but if I
can see the derivative of this is this
therefore I can say the primitive of
this is this right because I'm Angie
different yet I'm just thinking okay
where did this come from well it's in
this particular unusual format G - on G
- G okay
so when you see of a rational function
like this and they say well okay what
would what was its primitive where did
it come from
there's only one kind of function
appreciate it and you end up with F -
what they have to change actually
whatever okay must have come from the
law all right yeah it's not it's not F -
on earth is it not quiet anyway because
I'm sign is not the derivative of cos is
it that's pretty close right what is the
derivative of cos it's a negative sign
right so if I had I have this okay this
this is G - on G we have to actually F
whatever you want to call it
okay so what do you think the primitive
oh this is this is this is gonna be a
log of some economist Lord
oh just log of cause yes yeah
you think about how this would work if I
if I went back the other way you're
differentiate and you go okay
it'll be F - what if G - one do you mean
- I mean cause it works okay so so how
am I gonna fix it up if I if I don't
have a minus sign there let's put one
there okay now if I'm gonna put one
there I can't just you kind of x numbers
just because he wants you right so I I
have to whatever I do to this this
shouldn't be any net change any total
change okay so this should be if I want
to if I put a minus sign there right in
order to make that the derivative of the
denominator right in order to restore it
and make sure I have any a third off
I've got to put another minus sign way
out the front okay does that make sense
cuz now that's that is 10 the negatives
cancel this is still 10 even though it's
a weird way to write it
okay so therefore I don't just expect
what's the what's the antiderivative
what's the
move this it's just this right with a
minus sign at the front just in the same
way is if I put a minus sign here
I'm pretty - on there right does that
make sense
all right so now you can see even though
I was interested in sheep functions when
I started looking at logs okay because
this particular trig function doesn't
end up back in a trig function when you
find it's primitive
she's somewhat weird gotta be careful
with us yeah yes so there's issues of
domain here aren't there right because
10 except for its asymptotes it just
goes forever yeah it's it exists for all
rebelling except for the dad sometimes
whereas logs I'm not like that you need
to have positive values for cause okay
so therefore and we're going to deal
with the intricacies of this later you
have to be careful about the
relationship between these two but
that's still the primitive function